matt has some remarkable progress in the
fight against covid more than 95 million
americans have received at least
one dose so far one vaccine dose that is
and the bind administration says
90 percent of adults should be eligible
for the vaccine
in less than three weeks however the
biden administration is also sounding an
alarm that another surge in cases
may be on the way ed o'keefe reports now
from the white house
i'm going to pause here i'm going to
lose the script
cdc director dr rochelle walensky with a
stark warning as covid19 cases are up 11
over the past week and i'm going to
reflect on the recurring
feeling i have of impending view we have
so much to look forward to so much
promise and potential of where
we are and so much reason for hope
but right now i'm scared at a time when
millions are on the road for spring
break wallenski and president biden are
discouraging
non-essential travel the president is
once again calling on mayors and
governors to reinstate
mass mandates please this is not
politics
reinstate the mandate if you let it down
and business should require mass as well
at least
eight states have dropped mass and
social distancing restrictions in recent
weeks
with no signs of reversing course
meanwhile
the biden administration says it's not
taking the lead on developing so-called
vaccine passports or certificates
now in use in new york china and europe
there's concern about americans having
access to the technology needed
and patient privacy the government here
is not
viewing its role as the place
to create a passport nor a place to hold
the data of of citizens
that's because officials know many
americans won't want the government or
private companies
tracking your vaccination data florida's
republican governor
ron desantis it's completely
unacceptable
for either the government or the private
sector
to impose upon you the requirement that
you show proof of vaccine
to just simply be able to participate in
normal
society so the administration isn't
going to develop those passports but is
going to set some guidelines on how to
do so
we're waiting for those today here at
the white house the president is set to
sign an extension
of the paycheck protection program
eligibles businesses
now have until may 31st to apply for aid
and the cdc is extending
the federal moratorium on evictions
through the end of june
to help those that need a little more
assistance adriana
ed thank you